the widow of a man killed by an Arizona
police officer is speaking out after the
officer was found not guilty of murder
charges body camera video was released
after the verdict last week we have to
warn you here that this video is very
disturbing it shows Daniel shaver
pleading for his life just before he was
shot back in 2016
Adriana Diaz spoke with Shavers Widow
her name is Lena Street then interview
you will see only on CBS News he knew
his life was about to end he was scared
the only person in the hallway who was
fearful for his life was Daniel shaver
nearly two years ago Mesa Arizona police
officer Philip Brailsford found Schaefer
intoxicated in a hotel room after a
report of a man waving a rifle from the
window there was an execution you had a
man begging for his life and he was shot
five times for what Brailsford who was
later fired testified he believes shaver
was reaching for a gun in his waistband
what do you make of him saying he had a
split second to decide what to do when
he thought your husband was pulling a
gun I understand the officers have hard
jobs and I think that this goes back to
the Mesa police supports training shaver
had no gun on him but police found two
pellet rifles used for his pest control
job in his hotel room pretty much every
use of force a subject matter expert
that reviewed this case absolutely said
he acted consistently with his training
Sweden shaver have two daughters on
Monday she received a call from her
eight-year-old school she tried to
choking herself while she was at school
and told her friend that she wanted to
die
what did not only say to you when you
saw her she told me that she wanted to
be with her dad for CBS this morning
I'm Adriana Diaz
sweeeeet says that her fight for justice
is not over she believes that crucial
evidence was left out of the trial and
she wants the Department of Justice to
investigate her husband's death it's so
tough to look at that video it seems
like there are other options - take off
your shirt just lay there till we get to
you it's just very unfortunate that it
ended that way agreed with him I agree
with you